so this semester we were working on
clampy which is an iPhone mount for the
wheelchair and the kind of special
thinking about Plan B was you know there
are their iPhones there are plenty of
iphone accessories but the client we
were working with had kind of a special
range of abilities and disabilities so
what we were building for the wheelchair
was not only about but also one that
could accommodate his range of motion
and his strength and I ended up being
something that was what to bill enough
for him in his needs and still allowed
him the kind of independence that he
wanted in everyday interruption
so I've actually done a bit of work in
assistive technology in the past and
it's always really interested me I think
that working on assistive technology is
one of the best things that an engineer
can work on both because the problem is
quite interesting and because of every
engineer wants to build something that
helps people and this is one of the best
avenues to do that ok so the way this
class was presented to me was a course
sixth class that dealt with a client
with a disability and I was like oh I'm
forced to obviously I have no place
there but what I was told was actually
that you can come from completely
different backgrounds the main concept
is that you have a direct impact on
someone's life throughout the course of
a semester which is something almost
incomprehensible and I think you can
only get it a course at MIT is real life
faces and helping a person
so coming into the class I actually
didn't even have enough information to
build expectation almost I just knew
that it was it was going to be an
interesting opportunity to work on an
actual applied problem and the first few
years I spent at MIT I worked on a lot
of theoretical problems both in like
coursework and things of that sort and I
thought this would be a really cool
opportunity to like take my skills and
things that I've learned here and work
on a real project with a real person I
did learn a quite a few things that are
unexpected actually in class there's I
don't know you're kind of taught that
the things that are like most complex
are the most grand in a large sense but
when you're working with real people you
tend to sacrifice complexity to make
things work almost where you might be in
a situation where like a solution that
takes you a thousand times longer to
implement might be marginally better but
like in the interest of time and speed
and you know moving the process forward
you're going to go for a simpler
solution
the thing I learned from that process is
that you constantly have to modify what
it is you are actually working on
because at the end of the day it's not
so much about being given a problem
statement that explicitly lists
everything you have to do but more about
building something that your client
wants and the biggest thing we learned
is that those desires can change over
time so it's more important not it's
more important to work on what the
client actually wants and build
something that you think he or she will
actually use as opposed to being fixated
on what like the initial project
proposal wants to
many touched on this
earlier but through a team dynamic and
working in multiple very iterations of
our design we found that assumptions are
the most dangerous thing and when you're
moving through various iterations a full
180 degrees pivot is not something to be
afraid of because that can save your
entire project and we found that it
actually did is we made a lot of
assumptions initially about our client
Aaron's abilities or disabilities and we
found we were compensating for a problem
he had never even had originally so we
did a pivot and created an item that he
would actually be able to use and enjoy
using
each disability has so many variations
errands with finds his paraplegia as
c-56 and there's so many ranges of
paraplegia he doesn't even fit within
one grade of it so I think that gives
you a little bit of an idea of how
different each person's disability can
be and defining your assistive
technology for just that one person is
the most important aspect because
they're your client but I think on a
grander scale we saw a problem with in
assistive technology is making it
accessible to as many people as possible
while still satisfying that disability
I'd say that's a great challenge in
assistive tech
the blog's gave us a lot of context
because to a large degree the posts
could be about anything and this was
important because we know that we are
engineers and sometimes when you're
working on these problems when you get
too deep into it you almost forget why
it is you're doing this and I guess the
biggest thing that the blog's did for me
is that after a day spent and like the
machine shop or a day spent
brainstorming design ideas you could go
to the blog and just read articles about
you know people with disabilities the
struggles that they face how people are
looking to combat those struggles and it
kind of gives you a renewed sense of
motivation
I'd say it's very important for the
professor to realize that we may have no
experience with user centered design I
know these two did actually but I
personally did not and when it's about
your client it's a lot less about what
design process you're used to and a lot
more about what the client wants to
receive from you at the end of this
semester so focusing a lot on client not
making assumptions and I think the
professor's did a very good job that's
course though